retour en France maintenant avec à ce
stade du journal je crois une
recommandation qui s'impose
âme sensible s'abstenir Bernard
Marchetti va en effet vous raconter
cette horrible faits divers né de la
découverte de valises sanglante dans le
bois de Boulogne s'agissait des restes
d'une jeune Néerlandaise assassinée par
un étudiant en japonais dans des
conditions vous allez le voir
effroyables
cet homme est un anthropophage il
s'appelle ici Sagawa japonais né à Kobe
il y a 32 ans jeudi dernier il a tué
d'une balle dans la tête sa camarade de
faculté René hartwels une hollandaise de
25 ans puis il a défaissé le corps la
conserver chez lui jusqu'à samedi soir
et pendant ces deux jours à plusieurs
reprises il a mangé des morceaux de la
chair de sa victime lorsque les
policiers l'ont arrêté hier soir il y en
avait encore dans son réfrigérateur
Sagawa avait connu René artevelt au
centre de Censier où il étudier la
littérature comparée elle le considérait
comme un bon camarade mais lui était
amoureux et la poursuivait de ses
avances l'hollandaise était sage jeudi
une fois de plus et la repousser sa Gava
il l'a tué et c'est en voulant se
débarrasser des restes de sa victime au
bois de Boulogne que le japonais a été
repéré par des témoins et par le
chauffeur de taxi qu'il y avait conduit
là en face du chalet des îles il avait
tenté de jeter ses deux valises dans le
grand lac samedi vers 20h30 mais il a
été vu et les valises sanglantes sont
restées sur la berge la police a été
aussitôt averti l'enquête a donc été
courte
on l'a cueillit hier soir chez lui rue
herlanger dans le 16e arrondissement de
Paris l'épreuve était accablante et
cette nuit ici au Quai des Orfèvres
Sagawa a tout avoué et il a dit que ses
désirs sexuels avaient toujours été
accompagnés de pulsions
anthropophagiques mais que ces pulsions
disparissaient avec l'assouvissement de
ses désirs alors la résistance de la
pauvre Renée arbels aurait donc été la
cause d'une meurtre et de
l'accomplissement horrible de ces
instincts les plus sauvages le japonais
cannibale comme on l'appelle a quitté
Paris ce matin trois ans après son crime
horrible il avait tué son ami une jeune
femme de 25 ans hollandaise il l'avait
ensuite dépecé avant de commencer à la
manger reconnu irresponsable cet homme
de 37 ans sera interné dans son pays au
Japon ce matin Gaëlle m'ont l'a eu qu'a
rencontré le défenseur disait Isa Kawa
qui parle pour la première fois de cette
affaire hors du commun
va donc pouvoir échapper à la publicité
morbide faite autour de lui c'est Guy
fougiez préfet de police de Paris qui a
pris cette décision parfaitement légale
Sagawa sera internée dès son arrivée à
Tokyo des examens au scanner ont permis
de déceler des anomalies au cerveau il
était jusqu'à ce matin soigner à
Villejuif son avocat explique le
pourquoi d'une telle décision
tout d'abord il était anormal qu'il soit
à la charge des contribuables français
il y a une décision définitive de
non-lieu parce que il est infirmemental
et dans ces conditions il n'y avait
aucune raison de le conserver la famille
de Sagawa est-elle beaucoup intervenue
dans cette affaire elle est intervenue
comme toute famille doit intervenir
c'est-à-dire que Monsieur et Madame
sagoa sont venus en France ils ont vu
leur fils et qu'ils l'ont soutenu ce que
je voudrais dire surtout c'est que cette
affaire qui est un véritable drame est
un drame pour deux familles bien
évidemment pour la famille de la victime
parce que c'est le crime est un crime
horrible mais également pour la famille
dci Sagawa car avoir un fils qui a
commis des fêtes telles que ceux qui
étaient reprochés c'est une véritable
catastrophe dans un milieu familial et
je veux dire que la mère dit Saïd Sagawa
était passée dans un hôpital
psychiatrique elle aussi et que le père
dernièrement a fait a fait une attaque
en aujourd'hui parle-t-il de son crime
ah ça c'est très difficile parce que
tout à la fois il le rejette et
ils sont je crois que c'est un garçon
qui souffre énormément qui souffre de ce
qu'il a fait et qui souffre
effectivement de la publicité que l'on a
fait autour de ce crime
cette impulsion me torturer et me
dominait depuis de longues années ces
quelques mots écrit par ici Sagawa sont
extraits d'un livre qui a eu un succès
retentissant au Japon la lettre à Sagawa
de judokaran cette longue confession
désormais traduite en français rencontre
peu de succès chez nous
c'est comme une sorte de j'allais dire
de d'analyse ou de psychothérapie il
s'explique il essaye de s'expliquer ce
qu'il a pu ce qu'il a fait et ça je
crois que il faut pas parler de
complaisance il recherche les raisons
pour lesquelles il a fait ça et
pensez-vous qu'il a des chances de les
trouver mais je ne sais pas mais c'est
pour ça qu'il faut qu'il soit soigné au
Japon
parmi des médecins japonais par des gens
de sa culture par des gens qui vont
essayer d'extraire de lui
ce qu'il a effectivement d'inquiétant
mais je vous l'ai dit s'agit de
d'anomalies mentale et je ne sais pas si
on y arrivera en termes de criminalité
le Japon est l'un des pays les plus sûrs
du monde un simple chiffre pour le
confirmer en une journée sur l'ensemble
du territoire japonais la police reçoit
en effet deux fois moins d'appel de
détresse et que celle de la police de
New York les Japonais ont mis en place
un réseau très dense de petits
commissariats de quartiers ce qui permet
d'avoir constamment des criminels aussi
dangereux que l'homme que l'on avait
alors baptisé le japonais cannibale
reportage de nos envies spéciaux Jérôme
Boni Tristan Le Braz le Coban c'est ce
petit commissariat de police que l'on
trouve à tous les coins de rue on y
pratique une police de proximité c'est
grâce au 15200 cobanes répartis dans
tout le Japon qu'il y a ici 9 fois moins
de crimes de sang qu'aux États-Unis les
policiers savent qui est qui dans chaque
quartier
ils savent par exemple qui est essai
Sagawa cet homme que la presse a
surnommé le japonais cannibale depuis le
meurtre d'une étudiante hollandaise
suivie d'anthropophagie à Paris il y a
16 ans après quatre ans d'internement à
la santé puis en hôpital psychiatrique
il est libéré au Japon en 85
il écrit des articles des livres
s'exhibe dans des films porno et
apparaît même dans des émissions de
télévision
cannibales ont disparu évidemment un je
ne veux pas recommencer mais je ne suis
pas ce 4 donc vraiment je ne connais pas
c'est pour ça je voulais savoir pourquoi
j'ai eu l'occasion de ce genre mais
aucun psychiatre
ne savait pas analyser
le commissaire de son quartier c'est lié
d'une amitié toute professionnelle avec
Sagawa pour mieux le surveiller
c'est la sécurité par la prévention
des policiers toujours au contact de la
population
les habitants viennent spontanément
demander leur chemin ou même donner des
renseignements sur des activités
suspectes
ce lycéen lui rapporte un portefeuille
qui la trouvait il décline habituel
offre de récompenses
ça m'est déjà arrivé qu'on retrouve au
portefeuille non non moi je veux rien
d'ailleurs il y avait pas d'argent
dedans les Japonais ont exporté dans
plusieurs pays ce système d'ilotage
grâce auquel Tokyo la ville la plus
grande du monde est aussi la plus sûre
jour et nuit
je rentre presque bon après minuit mais
normalement il y a pas de danger et à
Tokyo vraiment safe toutes les femmes
filles sortent mais normalement il y a
pas d'agression chaque soir Sagawa va
dîner chez ses parents il est libre de
ses mouvements mais rien d'alarmant la
situation est en principe sous contrôle
[Musique]